and you're supposed to believe there's a
bunch of like 12 year old i think
canadian kid sitting around a campfire
being like and then she died like what
no no that show is like what's this
story all about right
exactly
oh sorry for scaring you we just lost
all our canadian viewers
nina
what are some of the disturbingly dark
kids franchises
that scarred you for life
so as a child of the 90s there was
really only one option for me to pick
and it was are you afraid of the dark a
show that i still cannot believe anyone
thought was acceptable for young kids so
today i went through i wasn't even brave
enough to go through youtube clips of
the scariest episodes i just had to find
lists and even the gifts kind of scared
me so there's like the one that
i don't like clowns i don't think
anybody actually i like everyone's like
oh i'm afraid of clowns i think that's
probably just universal i think we're
all scared of clowns um they're creepy
but there's like multiple episodes
involving clowns there's one where a kid
steals a clown's nose and he's haunted
by the clown after that which i guess
teaches cuz the valuable lesson of like
don't steal from clowns specifically
which i just don't think
it's super applicable in everyday life
like stealing's fine but clown knows
that's crossing a line don't steal
anything from a clown especially right
and then there's one like the the
grimace
it has the word like grimace in it and
it's this creepy like it's a comic book
villain that comes to life but there's
no superhero to stop it but the one that
i think
stuck with me the most is where
like a young girl agrees to spend the
night in a haunted house and there's a
the you know a requisite little girl
ghost in there and she writes all over
the walls and she was like deaf and she
died of like starvation it's so dark it
is so unrelentingly dark and you're
supposed to believe there's a bunch of
like 12 year old i think canadian kid
sitting around a campfire being like and
then she died like what no no that shows
what's this story all about right
exactly
oh sorry for scaring you we just lost
all our canadian viewers
it's just a joke canadians are better
than americans it's just a joke we all
know it's true
you're above us because you're better
than us that's why it's all
geographically it's just
yeah i swear to god it's all from
insecurities because we are the worst
anyways um
[Music]
thanks for clearing that up but yeah i i
just like i watched i remember i would
be watching nickelodeon when this was on
when it aired in real time and i would
get up and walk out of the room the
second i heard that the opening credits
had like a creaking door as the very
first noise and i would hear that and i
would just leave i wouldn't even turn
the tv off i don't know why that wasn't
my first instinct but i would i would
probably
i'm guessing i maybe just left the house
just to be like i can't even be a
channel no i was like i can't even be in
the presence of this
i'm out of here knowing that it's even
being broadcast
the fact that it's on television
is just ruining yeah so
you asked me what scarred me for life
and i think i've delivered but it's
definitely yeah are you afraid of the
dark really cool concept great idea but
it's really really scary like it's still
scary
i'm 30 and i'm still scared of it so
it's fair it did its job way too well
and i don't understand who it was for
other than like kids without any anxiety
who love being scared out of their minds
yeah yeah
no thank you yeah
okay are you afraid of the dark is a
good pick yeah um you know what else is
pretty scary from that same era
roundhouse
remember round house what are we talking
about there brian
so this this gives you some insight into
my age i remember when are you for the
dark premiered on snick saturday and
nick oh i remember
the first slate of programming was are
you afraid of the dark i think the
secret world of alex mack yeah
in a show called round house so i
watched alex mack and are you afraid
well i didn't watch are you afraid of
the dark but i don't remember roundhouse
at all
roundhouse was um a bunch of theater
kids uh
doing like long-form sketches musical
sketches and dances so was it like a
predecessor to all that uh
i don't
it's difficult to describe
i've gotten so far off topic that i'm
just gonna stop talking about it all i
will say is that one recurring character
is a guy in a motorized recliner
um and uh there's probably some fun
visuals going on right here uh this part
may all get cut out because this is
stupid this is the ramblings of an old
tired man um this is so i'm just gonna
we'll
we'll look up roundhouse later did it
scar me for life no do i remember when
no one else does yes
um so i wanted to know why it was scary
yeah
it was just very weird it was very odd
roundhouse
look it up only on snick only on snick
saturday nick sniff i remember snick
this was the original snick one of the
arrangements i don't think anybody
remembers i think this is you
compartmentalizing your weird childhood
this is this is part one is this a
mandela effect this is part one of brian
remembers things that no one else has
ever even heard of so just get ready for
part two
and there were just people practicing in
your living room every night and you
were like this is a great tv show and
one of them was named true and she could
speak to the dead
tom what is what is one of the uh what
are the the kids franchises that scarred
you for life
okay
first up speaking to to are you afraid
of the dark
was it that or was it goosebumps that
had like the purple slime guy do you
guys remember that
there was i think that was there was
something
i think might have been goosebumps i
think it was goosebumps he didn't live
in a pool did he because that was are
you afraid of the dark
there were two separate episodes
are you thinking of the tar monster that
killed tasha yar on star trek the next
generation
how is it always oh man i'm not talking
about the weird theater troupe that you
grew up in
[Music]
i think it was goosebumps but if i'm
wrong it will probably say so at the
bottom of the screen
it doesn't matter i don't know if any of
this is it doesn't matter what matters
is anamorphs do you guys remember
animorphs oh my god yeah
remarkable okay so they made a tv show
out of it it was the series of kids
books from the 90s uh that were written
by
a sociopath named k.a applegate and they
were
they did a tv show with with one of the
the the cats that the
the guy played iceman in the x-men movie
that's right he's an identical twin so
it might it could have been him or john
ashmore yeah yeah pretty sure he was in
a lot of disney channel original movies
too like a lot of disney channel
original movies
i think you're absolutely right yeah
they made a they made a nickelodeon
live-action show out of it it was like
relatively bloodless but if you read the
books they were
sc they were
debilitatingly traumatizing i mean like
they they uh
it was so the idea was that there were
these kids who were uh basically giving
field reports on a war that they were
fighting in secret uh in the form of
these books
and uh they they wouldn't tell you like
their their full identities because this
is all really happening and you're in a
lot of trouble and anyone around you
could be an alien like slug that had
taken over your loved one's brains and
they were out there
that was the premise of anamorphs
yeah those were the bad guys they were
called the years and they uh they were
like don't i feel like i didn't get any
of that from the tv show
i know so then
you got these five kids and they get
alien superpowers to turn into whatever
animal they can get their hands on
whatever they can get their mitts on
they can turn into
and part of the process is that so
number one they could only stay an
animal for like a couple of hours or
else they would get stuck that way
forever and uh
and the other thing was uh when they
turned back into people they would they
would heal like anything that that
happened to they could go through like
grievous injuries and they would they
would come out the other end just fine
they would they would turn back into
humans they'd be okay but that meant
that these kids were like going into bed
and getting like limbs blown off of
themselves or like their guts are just
pouring out all over the concrete
there are 12 and that's and that was
there were like 50 of these books and i
loved them when i was a kid they were
incredible to me
that makes sense
just it's all this like body horror
terror
like
psychological warfare toe and like you
know the the main character's big
brother is secretly an alien and he's
like he's like do i kill my brother i
don't know what to do
it was not in the first book one of the
kids gets stuck as a bird and then he's
just a bird for like the next 20 books
his family just assumes that he's gone
and like nobody really asks any
questions this kid is just stuck as a
bird with uh with telepathy
it's uh
when they turn into these animals do
their lifespans change because i feel
like what if you turn into an animal
that has like a fraction of the lifespan
of a human being
well see that's the thing you gotta you
gotta turn back within a couple hours or
else you get stuck so like the lifespan
thing doesn't really really come into
play no but what if you get stuck like
now see that's a great
so like 30 books in they do the whole uh
they do the whole like evil hulk like
when sam beckett ran into like the evil
libra towards the end of quantum leap
they got a bad anamorph uh another kid
joined them and he turned out to be just
a real piece of work uh so their
solution
to this kid
who was ruining all their lives was to
trick him into turning into a rat
and then they trapped him on an island
like underground so that he couldn't
turn back into a person
this is bonkers
the yeah so they got the real villain
now
yeah right
yeah and so so here's the other thing so
when they turn into animals they can all
talk to each other through telepathy
like that's how they communicate
so what you wind up with is this like
12-year-old kid who was a brat
stuck as a rodent living out on an
island and then at the end of the book
they just mentioned that there's like
urban legends about if you if you drive
a boat past this island you'll just hear
screaming in your head because there's
like ah
i'm filming this at night and i am not
going to sleep
no it's bananas
it's so bad they wind up late
they go back to the kid eventually like
i said there's like 50 books in the
series i didn't read all of them like
you you kind of age out of uh
animal fight books or you get too
traumatized and you just move on yeah or
you just yeah you just can't read
anymore uh and that's why you don't join
birds
right and that's what and moral of the
story i don't trust birds that's why i
don't i don't trust birds either they're
shady
why are they always in groups what are
they planning
i would love to do another episode
called why we shouldn't trust parents
just completely no more pop culture just
for just for 20 minutes just let's just
have a right mickey rooney style video
about why we don't you're andy rooney
sorry not me rooney
i have two
the first one i have everybody knows
about the violet beauregard scene from
willy wonka and the chocolate factory
it's just that scene
that scene i was shopping with my mom at
kids kidsrus all right b
for those who don't recall kids or us
was toys r us's kids clothes store yeah
and one of the few things that they had
there to make it seem more fun because
you weren't buying toys you were just
buying clothes because they had a video
screen set up that all the kids who were
there with their moms were like picking
out their like sweatpants or whatever
could watch for a few minutes before
they had to go to the fitting room so i
remember they had willy wonka in the
chocolate factory on and this scene is
playing of this girl's face turning
purple and then she starts to blow up
and they're like you're going to explode
and this
i i don't remember how old i was i had
to been like five or six years old
it ruined me it ruined my brain
terrifying it's like to this day
that scene gives me the chills i do not
like to think about it well to be fair
that whole movie is
yes really frightening like the augustus
gloop scene is horrifying the ride down
the river is straight out of apocalypse
now like i would not be surprised if
scorsese stepped in and directed that
scene again martin sheen's like playing
an oompa loompa in the back
a lot of that movie is really really
scary so
yeah i support this choice yeah i was
not on board with a willy wonka reboot
until just now when you
you gave us a world where martin sheen
plays
maybe he plays all of them if everyone
wants today's martin martin
to do that i almost said martin's short
and that would work i do too that would
that would work better yeah okay so
that's that's the one that's the obvious
one but the one i wanted to show you
guys i have a video clip that i'm
popping in here so please boot this up
so anxious
this is a show from the 80s called
spartacus and the sun beneath the sea
this was on nickelodeon in the 80s it
was a french animated cartoon that they
dubbed into english
i'm going to read you the introductory
monologue that they speak over the
introductory animation these are the
first words that you hear when watching
this children's show
ever since the time of the great
cataclysm the arcadians have lived deep
in the center of the earth they believed
they were the only survivors of this
great devastation their civilization
thrived under the power of their son the
terror until it began to fail in
desperation the children of arcadia
broke the law and entered the forbidden
archives searching for a solution what
they discovered gave them hope anxiously
they used their special powers and
created a messenger to the people above
they named her arcana
what's going on here brian this is a
show i watched as a child
um no i'm watching the clip that you
sent us and uh
i don't mind saying
i would have
accused you of making this up if you
haven't yeah
if you had not shown me this clip
did you draw this last night
i wish it says it was uploaded at 6am
and it has two views
[Music]
[Laughter]
so this is a show i i watched this show
that's not true disclaimer that's not
true
i watched the show as a kid i don't
remember understanding it it's just some
weird post-apocalyptic adventure
underground with weird fantasy robot
dinosaur i don't know feels like the
matrix but for kids
it's disturbing to witness it makes no
sense i just sent you another clip there
were these two little armadillo guys
named bick and back and they did you
know i was noticing them and i was
wondering if they did yeah i had i had
questions about bacon oh god
so there's your dance there's the dance
and there's a whole song which we're not
going to play here
but i encourage everyone watching this
to look up bick and back from spartacus
and the sun beneath the sea you'll see
this looks like
yeah it looks like he-man if it was made
by one of those crappy companies that
did like the the bible cartoons from
when you were a kid
this looks like
the world's worst acid trip
like this you never want to have
so there was a period of time hard to
believe now but there was a period of
time where you were a child and then
there wasn't an internet so you just
like remembered things from your
childhood but couldn't confirm or deny
their existence yeah longest time i
thought maybe i dreamed this show
yep
because it's so weird and strange and
very disturbing it's not necessarily
intentionally disturbing it's like a fun
adventure for kids where these two kids
from the surface are like drawn into
this strange fantasy adventure under the
earth but
it's clearly like made by people with
diseased brains so i don't know yes the
french there's my answer to the
beginning of the conversation again
everybody's equal except the french i
was waiting for a punchline so
i had that exact same thing but with a
uh it was with a cartoon special from
like the late 80s or early 90s called
the cartoon all-stars oh
is this where they all told the kid not
to smoke pot don't do yeah don't smoke
that pot cause like it's full of the tim
curry tar monster from ferngully and uh
yeah are you familiar with this
no
in the in the morning
late 80s early 90s all of the cartoons
of the day teamed up to tell one kid not
to smoke that weed wow it was like it
was one of the last
moves that the uh the bush
administration did it was they put
together this video of uh the first the
first one maybe it was the reagan
administration the ninja turtles were
there i'm pretty sure that sounds like
it sounds like oh i was gonna say it
sounds like a nancy doing but it was
ninja turtles
slimer ghostbusters
and he like he opens the whole thing up
by saying hey kids i just want to remind
you i think it's barbara bush i thought
it was barbara bush i think you're right
i i think it was the book but it does
sound like a reagan thing and yeah no
you're right so so slimer is there
telling people not to do drugs which is
hilarious
because he's based on jim belushi john
right
right
yeah because it came out of the minds of
all of these old snl
yeah it doesn't matter right uh bugs
bunnies there
i think alvin and the chipmunks might be
out definitely they're absolutely there
winnie the pooh shows up to say hey i
don't smoke crack like it's it's
it is it's incredible it's like 20
minutes long there's like 80 different
uh uh
does our senior hall show up or did i
make that part up
wait
maybe tom i have a creepy one that
i know like that kind of like it i had
just had to make sure it was real are
you guys familiar with bubbas
no
oh boy i'm sending a photo
boobaz
they're really creepy
um and it was i think banned in a few
countries for being too scary
holy oh it was like i remember this
it was like did they lay eggs
i think so
in your brain but like they would
ah and like it was really really scary
and there's a website where you can like
play games related to boobas that are
equally as frightening that involve like
it'll just have like people like stock
photos of actual humans like dying in
the mini games anyway this show was
actually banned for being too creepy it
was advanced
yeah
yeah if you want to horrify yourself
just spend a while on the internet
looking at boobas i gotta say
i want to make entertainment for kids
because this sounds like a great scam
you can do anything no you can do it
literally and right yeah yeah it sounds
like you know
yeah yeah the internet is just this
vacuum that is never going to be filled
and nobody's ever going to check on all
of it no i think it's a brilliant idea
you remember the casper movie from the
90s where they're like yeah i'm a dead
kid i froze to death
yeah that's like a 10 minute scene where
it just explains that mortality is
always
[Laughter]
remember hocus pocus when they turn a
kid into a cat for like his whole life
and then he goes to heaven at the end
yeah
i'm sorry like we all love hocus pocus
but that's objectively really messed up
all right well i think we've decided it
we're all going to go into children's
television suit yeah and create
something even more horrifying make our
nightmares their reality
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
episode